When writing web apps,
you'll encounter a lot of APIs
you'll have to talk to.
Some of them might
be JavaScript APIs
that don't involve
much more than calling
a function in JavaScript.
Other APIs as are
provided by third parties
and require you to make
HTTP requests yourself.
A RESTful API is
one that follows
a design called REST that works
especially well with HTTP.
REST stands for
Representational State Transfer.
But let's be honest, that isn't
really a very descriptive name.
Not all APIs follow the
rest pattern, but many do.
So let's take a look at
the underlying concept.
The basic entities are
collections and objects
inside those collections.
The general pattern to
retrieve items from collections
is using a GET request with
both the collection name
and the unique item
name in that collection.
For example, if I want
to look up Richard,
I'd send this request,
and the server
would get the record containing
the data about Richard.
If I wanted to update
the data in that record,
I'd use a PUT request and
append the updated information
to the request.
Every subsequent GET
request should now
yield the updated record.
A POST request is used
very similar to PUT.
But instead of updating
existing records,
you use it to
create new records.
Notice that you
usually do not provide
the name under which the
new record will be created
but let the server make
that choice for you.
The response to
that POST request
is usually a redirect to
the newly created record.
And lastly, DELETE is
just what you think it is.
It removes items
from the collection.